- So I wanna start everything
with just a one-minute clip
written by our special guest,
from the HBO show Treme,
so let's do that, cool.
Hopefully the volume will work, okay.
- But we're gonna have potholes
that just swallow your whole
fuckin' car, you feel me?
- You're obsessive about potholes.
- Somebody's gotta call
these motherfuckers out.
- I agree.
- [Presenter] He's
running for city council.
- You agree, really?
Jacques Morial, the scion
of a great political dynasty
agrees with me.
- Hey, that shit is funny,
Greased Palm Sunday.
- Pot for potholes, don't forget that one.
- The satire, it's good,
but you have a chance
to raise some serious questions
that none of these other
motherfuckers are gonna touch.
- I do?
- Look,
here we got some serious
challenges, we've got
(garbled audio)
we got expropriation of people's homes,
we got when they're gonna
reopen Charity Hospital,
and then there's this big nasty question
about who can come home and who can't
come home.
- Right.
Here's an idea; why don't
you be my campaign manager?
- Not gonna happen.
But look, what I can
do is I can hook you up
with some real effective public exposure
so we get these issues on the table.
Now, that's if you really
wanna kick it up a notch.
- Hell yeah.
- You should go for it, Davis.
- Do you really think I can win this?
- The election?
No fucking way.
- [Presenter] (laughing) Okay.
- I was just checking.
- Yeah, that's it.
Alright, great.
So that scene, written by
our guest author Tom Piazza,
gives you just I think, a, thank you,
gives you just the smallest
sense of his talent,
his ability to capture human ambition,
making something out of nothing,
small but stinging disappointment,
and the familiar strangeness
of racial politics
in the broadest sense of the term.
It's also really funny, and appropriately
delightfully drops the F-bomb.
Okay, so I'll rewind now a little bit,
thank you all so much for being here,
I have a more formal
version of that thank you,
so let me read it.
The Franke Seminars and
Lectures are intended
to present important
topics in the humanities
to a wide and general audience, and to tie
interdisciplinary undergraduate education
to the work of distinguished
visiting scholars.
Endowed by Richard and
Barbara Franke in 2004,
this series is organized each year
in conjunction with an
undergraduate seminar
taught by a Yale faculty
member, or Yale faculty members,
and develops a theme of broad
interests in the community.
These seminars form an important component
of the humanities curriculum,
and we are grateful
for the extraordinary support
that the Frankes continue to
provide for these occasions,
so thank you to them and
thank you to all of you
for being here.
Mr. Piazza is the author
of an astonishing 12 books,
including the novels A
Free State, My Cold War,
and City of Refuge, along
with Devil Sent the Rain,
Music and Writing in Desperate Times,
Why New Orleans Matters,
and Blues and Trouble; 12 Short Stories.
City of Refuge won the Willy Morris Award
for Southern fiction,
and his My Cold War won
the Faulkner Society Award.
Why New Orleans Matters received
the Louisiana Endowment for the Humanities
Book of the Year Award,
and Blues and Trouble won
the James Michener Award.
Piazza is a richly
deservedly-decorated author,
add to this a Grammy.
Mr. Piazza received a
Grammy for his album notes
to Martin Scorsese Presents
the Blues; A Musical Journey.
Indeed, Mr. Piazza has been
a longtime preeminent writer
of American music, notably jazz, blues,
bluegrass, and country.
These writings as freestanding books
as articles in The New
York Times, The Atlantic,
and everywhere else, or
part of larger anthologies,
have earned him a whole
other chest of awards,
and of course he's a principal writer
for the HBO series Treme.
Mr. Piazza went to Williams College,
received an MFA in fiction
from the world-renowned
Iowa Writer's Workshop,
and he has been a Writer in Residence
at several colleges and universities,
including Hobart and
Williams Smith Colleges
and Loyola University.
For the seminar that I
teach with Crystal Feimster,
New Orleans and the American Imaginary,
we've read Piazza's City of
Refuge, Why New Orleans Matters,
and his short story Brownsville,
and we had a really wonderful
conversation with him
before you all got here, so
you're late, but it was great.
So here's the tiniest
sliver of what memorizes,
mesmerizes and moved us;
Piazza conjures orbs of feeling in words
that captivate completely,
even or especially
as they unsettle us.
His words, his characters, his narratives,
stun in their exposure of
anguish, rage, disorientation,
and those other emotions
so hard to sit with
but so necessary to read with.
In City of Refuge, drawing
on metaphors of the body
and humans' in-sor-ia, Piazza's
New Orleans is our friend,
our lover, we are nearly the city's widow,
and we come to love, long
for, and root for the city
as we do the two
families, black and white,
who improvised their way to
livable lives after the storm
and the grotesque failures
of government that followed
at every level.
And while some of the connective tissue
across our class's Piazza's readings
assembles loss, suffering, and
the resuscitating of selves
and communities alongside and
against atmospheric despair,
anxiety, and disposability,
I want to also say
Piazza can be really, really funny.
I found myself snorting in loud,
socially unacceptable
laughter at Jen's raunchy,
beyond raunchy one-liners
in City of Refuge,
and at Aunt Mimi's and
Desiree's reposts in Treme.
I'll hand over the mic
with words from our author.
In Why New Orleans Matters
Piazza responds to the question
so often asked in fall 2005,
usually posed rhetorically
with but the thinnest
veil to clock its racism,
why should we rebuild New Orleans?
His answer is the right
one, not only for the city,
but also for all cities,
for infrastructures,
for knowledge production,
for human invention.
"My answer," he offers,
"began with a notion
"that no city we know of would
exist in its current form
"or any other form if it
weren't for human efforts.
"Everything worthwhile
that humankind has achieved
"involves a rearguard
action against entropy.
"Without continual effort
it would all quickly revert
"to weeds and waste.
"Anyone who owns a house, tends
a garden, raises children,
"shaves, or does just about anything else
"knows this to be true; we
are always, in this sense,
"pushing back against nature."
Please welcome Tom Piazza.
(audience applauding)
- Well thank you.
Joe, do you want your phone?
- Ah, yeah.
- If I speak in a normal voice like this
you all can hear me?
Yeah, good.
Thank you, thank you
very much for coming out,
and I'm so happy to make
so many new acquaintances
and to see some old friends,
old and dear friends,
what a lovely occasion this is, thank you.
And I wanna thank, oh excuse
me, I wanna especially thank
Joe Fischel and Crystal Feimster
for making this all happen
in such a graceful and gracious way,
and Micah Cater was indispensable
and incredibly helpful,
and so thank you so much to those three,
and also to the generosity of
Richard and Barbara Franke,
and thanks also to the
Whitney Humanities Center
for hosting this.
So the title of this talk,
I guess you've seen the title of the talk
when it was advertised,
is Improvising Identity; New
Orleans and the American Dream.
And I have to apologize in advance
for delivering a lecture on improvisation
from a prepared written
text, sorry about that,
but anyway, we'll leave
time for discussion
at the end, hopefully.
So let me say that I deliver this lecture
with a degree of trepidation.
I'm a novelist, not a cultural
historian or ethnographer,
or not a polemicist certainly,
or even really an essayist.
As a novelist I work in an
arena in which opposites
are almost always simultaneously true,
and in which the truth, such
as it is, can't be formulated
in discursive terms, so I always feel
a degree of discomfort with discourse
that is aiming toward a certain point
because I always almost, as a,
I tack in the opposite
direction almost immediately.
I wanna say that the United
States, like New Orleans,
contains staggering and often seemingly
indigestible contradictions.
As soon as you say one
thing about the nature
of New Orleans culture,
much less American culture,
it seems that the
opposite is true as well.
I would say that both
cultures not only contain,
but are defined by the fact
of their massive internal contradictions,
which fact is almost
impossible to engage head-on
without getting overrun by
an armada of exceptions,
qualifications,
counterexamples, equivocations,
mitigations, heavy theoretical
artillery and sniper fire,
outright evidence to the contrary,
briefs for both defense and prosecution.
Instead, in other words
I'm trying to offer
a sustained argument
leading to a grand point,
what I will offer instead
is a series of patrols into,
or raids upon, a territory of questions
with no clear answers,
at the heart of which
lies a paradox that has vexed me
for my entire working life
as a writer and as a citizen.
How is it possible for
a nation as diverse,
as maddeningly contradictory
as the United States,
to consider itself a single
entity, a nation with a name.
How can its kaleidoscopically
diverse elements
be recognizably American
each in themselves,
and yet lend themselves
to a term, American,
that is definable only
in terms of the tension
among these elements?
Even the nation's motto, E
Plurbis Unum, from many one,
can be read in opposite ways
like one of those
ambiguous optical illusions
by putting the weight of meaning
either on the many or on the one,
and neither of those readings
is really wholly true,
only the tension between the two readings.
Stop me if I'm getting too
abstract for you too early.
So look, so the point is that these raids
that I'm gonna conduct are
plainly gonna be conducted
over swampy ground, and
sometimes covering the same tract
from different angles.
I've found hints of a way of
understanding this paradox
in New Orleans, where
I've lived for 24 years,
swampy ground, if ever
there were swampy ground.
If this 40-minute guerrilla
war that I'm going to
engage in for you here
has anything like a theme
it might be that New
Orleans should be seen
as a representative part
of the American tradition
of self-reinvention,
transformation, and possibility.
But I'm getting ahead
of myself, let me begin
on the more or less solid
ground of my own experience.
New Orleans is a place that
I loved in my imagination
from a very young age.
When I was 11 years old on
Long Island's South Shore,
any South Shore people here?
No Long Island people here?
Oh hell, okay that's it.
(audience laughing)
No, no, I'll continue, I'll continue.
So alright, on the South
Shore of Long Island,
it's sort of echt-suburbia,
Burger Kings and gas stations,
where I was raised, my
mother bought me a copy
of a book called Jazzmen,
originally published in 1939
and reissued in a bright
orange Harvest Books edition.
I'd been interested in musical performance
since The Beatles came
to the U.S. in early 1964
when I was eight, and like many others
I followed a trail of
recordings and crumbs
from The Beatles, to Chuck
Barry, to Muddy Waters,
to Robert Johnson, and
I think my mom figured
it was a short hop from there to jazz.
In any case, Jazzmen, that
book, is a romantic depiction
of jazz's early years, earliest years,
a collection of hagiographic
essays on early jazz musicians
such as King Oliver, Bix Beiderbecke,
and Louis Armstrong, their working lives,
and recordings and travels.
It contains a fantastic essay
on collecting old 78 records
in dusty antique stores
in dirt road towns,
and most important to me, a
thick section of photographs
in the middle.
The grainy, black and white images
taken back in the 1910s
and 1920s were mesmerizing.
Bands led by men with
names like Buddy Bolden,
and Bunk Johnson, and
Kid Ory, dressed in suits
or band uniforms holding
trumpets, and clarinets,
and trombones, and banjos.
These musicians were black and white,
although only rarely did
white and black musicians
appear in the same photographs.
Regardless of skin color,
they gazed into the camera,
through the camera,
straight into posterity,
clearly sure of their own
worth and place in the world.
There were photos of buildings too,
archaic-looking dance halls, and saloons,
and the occasional brothel
with names like Louth Gins,
and Tom Andersons, and
Big 25, and Mahogany Hall,
streets full of light and shadow
with names that were
in themselves a poetry;
Rampart, Perdido, Burg, well Burgundy,
which we pronounce as Ber-gone-dy,
some even named for the Greek muses;
Thalia, Euterpe, Terpsichore, Calliope,
which in New Orleans you
pronounce Cal-ee-ope, by the way.
My grandparents on
either side, both sides,
had come to America in the late 19-teens,
through Ellis Island, eyes firmly locked
on the American Dream,
and yet never quite able
to let go of the umbilicus connecting them
to the literal and figurative Old Country.
They presided over long Sunday dinners
with aunts and uncles,
recycling ancient resentments
and gossip, and had endless conversations
about this or that other cousin,
or uncle, or neighborhood,
speaking Italian about half the time.
Yet at the same time that they held on
to these ancient grudges
and secret handshakes,
they encouraged their children,
my father's generation,
to assimilate and lay
claim to the possibilities
afforded by this new country.
Their bookshelves held
inexpensive matched reprint sets
of Hemingway, Steinbeck, and Mark Twain,
as well as the 20 volumes
of the Book of Knowledge,
with their imposing
embossed ox blood-colored
faux leather bindings.
The children, not just of the Italians,
but the Irish and the Polish Catholics
and the Eastern European Jews took the cue
and moved out after World
War II, some of them anyway,
from Brooklyn and Queens
to the Long Island post-war suburbs
where every immigrant
could have the same house
and bleach their ethnic complexion
to roughly the same hue,
that seemed to be the idea anyway.
So Long Island South Shore,
where my parents settled,
with its endless stretches
of department stores
and Levittown-inspired
tract housing developments,
its yawning sky as yet
uninterrupted by big trees
or interesting-looking buildings,
represented an aggressively
asserted version of normalcy
after the unimaginable
sacrifices and hardships
and heartbreaks of the second World War,
a promised land for many of
those who had lived through it,
black and white, although
obviously coming down
more heavily on the white side.
But it was an eerily affectless
and rootless landscape
to a generation of adolescents
who came of age there,
myself included.
Those photos in Jazzmen became for me
a kind of treasure map, a set of clues
to what might be possible in life,
a taproot into a past that
could nourish the present
and future in ways I
could not yet imagine,
but which I could feel,
like the tangy air of coming springtime.
Two, this is the second raid,
this is a series of raids.
New Orleans is often characterized
as a special case kind of
place within the United States,
we talked about this a
bit, Joe and Crystal,
and somehow not entirely American.
Partly European, partly Caribbean,
divorced, or at least amicably separated
from the supposed American
ethos of hard work,
rugged individualism,
and capitalist venality.
This is not entirely inaccurate,
but it is most certainly
incomplete at best.
New Orleans is, in my view,
a quintessentially American place,
one which reflects and embodies
the tensions and ironies,
the survival strategies,
and the as yet unhealed
and inadequately addressed
wounds of the nation as a whole.
New Orleans, with its exposed
roots in France, in Spain,
in Africa, has offered a model
not of cultural assimilation,
that mythic and monstrous Melting Pot
that we all hear about, but
rather a cultural polyphony.
The city has fashioned
a collective identity
out of constituent national
and ethnic identities;
French, Italian, African,
Spanish, German, Irish,
the list is too long to continue.
The food, the music, the architecture
are famously amalgams of all the distinct
identifiable ethnic compounds,
and yet also unmistakably New Orleans.
This construction of what might be called
a cultural identity out of the tension
among wildly various
preexisting cultural identities
is nothing if not a paradox,
generating an endless
series of complications
and variations, Moire
patterns, that summon a reality
far more complex and richly textured
than any of their compounded parts,
and I think much the
same thing might be said
about the country as a whole.
Three.
America has never quite settled for itself
where it stands in
relation to the question
of inherited position,
of whatever variety,
versus social and cultural mobility.
The nation as a whole, and
New Orleans in particular,
afford the freedom and
sometimes the necessity
of switching identities,
assuming alternative identities.
At the same time they advance
a counterbalancing emphasis
on the centrality and
dominance of old families
and other types of lineage.
On the one hand, the injunction
to recreate yourself,
expand your horizons, go West, innovate,
on the other a sharply
articulated awareness
of family background,
class privilege, ethnicity,
race, gender identifiers.
This emphasis is asserted
the more strongly
in proportion to the social
flux amid which it exists,
and it can be found across
the class and ethnic spectrum.
The DAR, Mayflower Descendants,
The Social Register,
the old-line families of
New Orleans, of Boston,
of every major city, as well
as all the urgent identifiers
involved in what is usually referred to
as identity politics and
the abrupt rise and hunger
for DNA evidence of genetic background.
Ancestry.com should really
be called identity.com.
Does anybody know the story,
Nathaniel Hawthorne's story,
My Kinsman, Major Molineux?
Anybody know that one?
Oh great, I get to turn
you on to a good story.
Nathaniel Hawthorne's short story,
My Kinsman, Major Molineux,
oh man, you gotta read this,
it's one of the great American stories,
follows a young man from
the countryside named Robin
as he arrives in a
certain little metropolis
of a New England colony
in search of a supposedly wealthy relative
who's gonna set him up,
install him in a position,
and endow him with privilege
that he hasn't earned himself,
he's very young, he hasn't had a chance
to earn this position, but
he thinks this kinsman of his
is going to hook him up.
This is all fine with our young man,
but as he walks the streets inquiring
as to where he might find
his kinsman, Major Molineux,
he is met with hostility and ridicule,
until finally a wise and helpful spirit
invites Robin to wait
with him on the street
with the promise that Robin's
kinsman will soon pass by,
and he does, the Major does,
borne on a litter by a wild
mob, got up in crazy garb
with faces painted, with
wild music, by torchlight,
and he's been tarred and feathered.
As the joke sinks in for Robin,
the folly of leaning too
heavily on the expectation
that his antecedence,
his inherited identity,
will make his way for him
instead of having to
create it for himself,
his wise companion
enjoins him not to leave
and go back to the country,
but to remain in town
where he, quote, may rise in the world
without the help of your
kinsman, Major Molineux.
Remake yourself, live with the joke,
sustain tension between
the hand you were dealt
and what you make of it.
Improvisation is the word for
making your own variations
upon a set of givens,
and America has been an
improviser's culture,
nothing if not an improviser's culture.
The nation grew out of the
need to use and transform
what was to be found here,
in a landscape not just geographical,
but social and economic,
and the culture advances
this myth of improvisation
in countless ways from the comic
to the tragic end of the spectrum.
The leaving of home in search of a dream,
an elusive prize that often
turns out not to be worth it,
or an illusion, as in Bobby
Bare's great performance
of the song Detroit City,
anybody know that song?
Ah, look at you guys.
Okay, I hope you all are taking notes,
you need to go check this stuff out.
Detroit City, it's great,
it's a song that's sung
in the persona of a guy who
has left his home down south
and goes up north to work
in the factories in Detroit,
and he says by day I make the
cars by night I make the bars,
hey, okay, and then there's
this refrain in it of,
♪ I wanna go home ♪
♪ Gee, but I wanna go home ♪
Thank you, anyway.
(audience laughing)
But that refrain, of I wanna go home,
lives underneath American song
and literature consistently,
as it became more and more American,
a chorus underneath all
the restless traveling
and optimistic bluster, it's
there as an ostinato of sorts.
The voyage may be the traveling
north from a South Shore
to an opportunity, or
the leaving of the East
with its establishment norms
heading for the frontier of the West
with all of its possibilities
and its dangers,
or it could be Nick Carraway
leaving the Midwest for New York
with all of its own Gatsby-esque
promises and dangers,
the old paradigm so often to
be found in European novels,
certainly of the provincial
coming to the city
to make his way upward,
literally and figuratively,
a novel saved from an excessive reliance
on the European model by the
resoundingly symbolic invention
of Gatsby, with his insatiable hunger.
Our two greatest American
novels contain multitudes;
Huckleberry Finn, of course,
with its improvising protagonist
who just wanted to go somewhere,
he weren't particular,
and his encounter with the grand
array of riverfront con men
and masqueraders in the company of Jim,
an enslaved person who is making
his own gamble on freedom,
and whose fate is inextricably
bound up with Huck's.
And then there's Moby-Dick,
with its Pequod populated
by every imaginable
nationality and ethnic group
presided over by Ahab and
his monomaniacal quest
for something unattainable;
domination over nature,
over life itself, a
mania that leads to doom.
In Twain's book everything turns out okay,
and in Melville's book everything ends
in shards and splinters.
Which vision prevails?
We hang suspended between both.
Four.
The novelist Ralph Ellison once remarked
that "The search for identity
is the American theme."
He gave that search a form
in his novel Invisible Man,
which we talked about today in class,
in which the narrator and
central character lacks a name
as well as a fixed identity, excuse me,
and is constantly looking to other people
and external situations to lend him one.
And yet the word search
feels problematic to me,
with its implicit positioning
of identity as a fixed goal,
something findable,
preexisting, awaiting discovery.
The novel's protagonist
never does disembark
at some safe harbor of a found,
or even a constructed identity, after all,
only calls a supposedly
temporary truce with that goal,
as if on the next try he might emerge
from his underground hole
and finally grasp it,
create the uncreated features of his face,
in his twist on Stephen Dedalus' desire
to create the uncreated
conscience of his race.
But perhaps the idea of that search itself
is not just elusive, but a
mistake, an error in perception.
Perhaps identity in the American sense,
the broadest American sense, involves
not so much the search for,
much less the discovery of,
the single preexisting role awaiting one,
some final secure off-the-rack identity,
or even the creation of
a single definitive face
for oneself, as it does
the constant transformation
of the given; the conversion
of objects into subjects,
the act of creative argument
with one's own assumptions.
I would say that identity is to be located
in the nature and quality
of that transformation,
that conversion, that argument,
a dynamic engagement with
it all, a kind of hologram
created by energies pointed
in different directions.
In an essay on Bob Dylan,
who I think is one of
the most representative
American artists who's ever done it,
in my collection Devil Sent the Rain,
I said I wasn't an essayist,
but it's an essay collection,
it's also got some journals,
examining the extraordinary
variety of American utterance
and reference to which Dylan
laid, and lays still, claim,
I tripped on the word
American, and the word America,
a couple times and I wrote this;
America, meaning what, again?
Cowboys and Indians?
New York City, Hollywood?
The Civil War, the CIA,
interstate highways, Main Street, Walmart?
John Wayne?
John Wayne Gacy?
Earl Scruggs, Mohammed Ali,
Rosa Parks, Don Rickles,
Flaco Jimenez, Edmund Wilson?
Redwood forests, Gulf Stream waters?
Ellis Island, Los Alamos?
America wants to include all possibility,
hence it takes up potentially
all the space there is,
it expands.
Something so internally contradictory
is of course a target for
every kind of projection.
The mind has trouble accepting
such intense contradictions
within the same entity,
their presence creates a profound anxiety.
Learning to accept them is a discipline,
to identify with the culture itself
means identifying with a high level
of tension among elements,
it means identifying
with the tension itself.
Five.
It's gonna be a long lecture, so.
Five, in The Birth of Tragedy,
Frederick Nietzsche sets
out his famous notion
of what he calls the
Apollonian and Dionysian
aspects of human nature,
positing a fruitful tension between them.
Roughly, and somewhat oversimply put,
the Apollonian tendencies are those
that pull in the direction
of order, measure,
hierarchy, and individuation,
and the Dionysian, or
Di-o-nee-sian aspects
represent the tendency toward
dissolution of a distinct self
in communal orgiastic activity
and altered states that exist,
to use his phrase, beyond good and evil.
On one side, morals, ethics, moderation,
on the other, impulse,
excess, unregulated passion.
He also states, if I read him correctly,
that the two sets of impulses exist
in a kind of corrective
relationship, one to the other.
American culture has always struggled
to maintain its balance
on this fault line,
like a tightrope walker
constantly making micro,
and sometimes macro corrections.
If any single place in the United States
distills the essence of
the contrast and tension
between the Apollonian and the Dionysian,
it would be New Orleans,
and never more fully
than at Mardi Gras time,
when the entire community almost,
participates in both
the Dionysian loosening
of moral ligature, in
masking, drinking, eating,
and doing all the other
stuff we know about,
and at the same time the
Apollonian reenactments
of traditions and pageantry
that go back well into the 19th century,
and really in some cases before that,
often in detail scripted down
to the smallest hand gesture, literally.
Whether we see bank
presidents who wear hoods
unhappily reminiscent of Klan outfits
riding on lavishly decorated
floats in the Krewe of Rex,
the always-white King of Carnival,
or the grand mirroring mockery
of the 100-plus year old
African American social club Zulu
with its own king and
court consisting primarily
of the city's black bourgeois elite
dressed in parody, bitter parody,
of supposedly African garb;
grass skirts and blackened faces,
or the Mardi Gras
Indians, made up primarily
of working class African
Americans who roam the streets
wearing extraordinary handmade suits
and singing songs and
performing ritualized gestures
that go back, again, well
into the 19th century,
is the mask that endows the individual
with the ability to transcend the given
and emerge into the
possibility of transformation.
In either case, this
transformation is sanctioned,
understood as a necessary
element in managing
and mediating energies that
might otherwise break loose
and do lasting damage to the social order.
This disillusion of the day to day self,
or rather the substitution of another self
that exempts one from the
usual responsibilities
and guidelines of social
standing, propriety, station,
location, affiliation, is
understood by all concerned
to be an assumed identity,
a mask that transforms you.
Six.
While all this is recognizable
as characteristically New Orleans,
we should also understand that masking
is not just a perennial,
but a defining element
of American culture as a whole.
It's of course true that masking
is part of the cultural fabric
in most places in the world
in ritual enactment and celebration,
but it has served important
additional purposes here
in our mythology-drenched
cultural landscape,
where social position,
(clears throat) excuse me,
ethnic background, gender identity,
even the mass appetite for team sports,
may be understood as a form of masking,
a shadow play of identity.
It has been a way of encoding
or channeling aspiration,
doubt, guilt, even unspeakable desire,
and has often in itself
served as a passport
to social mobility.
Members of marginalized groups
have often found it necessary
or desirable to become
virtuosos of the mask;
whether Jewish Americans who
have passed for gentiles,
or African Americans
with skin light enough
to allow them to, quote, pass for white,
in both cases is a way of
opening doors of opportunity
for themselves and their families
that might otherwise have remained closed.
The masquerade can go
both ways, of course.
The foundation of a recognizable
indigenous American musical performance
was blackface minstrelsy,
the most peculiar institution
of American culture in 19th century,
and well into the 20th, be it said,
the rock and roll of its time, in fact.
White performers blackened
their faces with burnt cork
and performed stylized and often,
as I said this in class,
viciously caricatured impressions
of supposed black types,
whether devious or carefree,
and scenes of idyllic life
on the old plantation.
This entertainment found
its first mass audience
in the north, where the scenes of blacks
portrayed as either
simple-minded or criminal
eased the collective white mind somewhat
about being complicit in
the perpetuation of slavery.
It would be nearly impossible to overstate
minstrelsy's influence on the course
of American popular entertainment.
Sam Philips, the charismatic founder
of the legendary Memphis
record label, record company
Sun Records, said sometime
around 1954 or 1955,
"Find me a white man who
can sing like a negro
"and I'll make a million dollars."
And when he discovered Elvis Presley
he made his million, and more, and more.
But 100 years before
that, white men singing
supposedly like negros dominated
the entertainment world.
The assuming of the mask
of blackness endures today,
in every white suburban high school kid
who imitates the gestures and
accents of rappers, homie,
that mask of blackness allowing
the expression of attitudes
and modes of expression
otherwise considered unacceptable
in so-called proper, i.e. white, society.
But blackface performance
was not the only form
of ethnic masking that became
wildly popular in the U.S.,
far from it.
The early 20th century, with
its mass influx of immigrants
from southern and eastern
Europe was a rich time
for ethnic impersonation.
Vaudeville drew upon a
gallery of stock characters
based on ethnic stereotypes,
and in fact provided an entrance ramp
from which so many German,
Irish, Jewish immigrants
made their way into the American
entertainment mainstream
like cars entering a
fast-moving interstate.
Jewish performers especially
have been ballet masters
of this kind of masking.
Often this entree actually
came from carrying on
the minstrel tradition, as
the singer Al Jolson did
in full blackface singing
songs like Mammy both onstage
and in the first popular talking picture,
The Jazz Singer, released in 1927,
songwriter Irving Berlin, who was Jewish,
providing a mostly Christian nation
with its holiday anthem White Christmas,
all the way to Bob Dylan,
born Robert Zimmerman,
Bob Dylan's appropriation
of everything he liked,
from ancient Anglo-Irish
ballads through country blues,
rock and roll, lyric poetry, and more.
Saul Bellow once remarked
that you were entitled
to steal anything in writing
that you were strong enough to carry out.
Freedom suggests itself as the readiness
to adopt as many masks as possible.
Seven.
New Orleans has been
called the land of dreams
in songs like Basin Street Blues
and Way Down Yonder in New Orleans,
but has anyone ever defined
that much-abused formulation,
the American Dream?
A thing devoutly to be wished, apparently,
a protean set of possibilities
that everyone defines
for himself or herself,
out of what an uneasy sleep
such a dream might come.
In any organized social context
one leads a double life, at least,
as both a private individual
and a member of the society.
In the United States
each individual carries
the weight of responsibility
for the fate of the
democratic enterprise itself,
this noble, flawed experiment
in which we are engaged.
Huckleberry Finn tries to
escape it for most of a novel,
but is finally forced into
assuming responsibility
for his choice regarding
the fate of his friend,
the escaped slave Jim.
In Moby-Dick the men on the Pequod
maintain their varied individual aspects
while performing their duties as seamen,
their limited responsibility
for the collective enterprise,
as that enterprise is hijacked
by the unstable genius Captain Ahab,
a commander in chief driven by revenge
walking the deck alone at all
hours, accepting no council,
tweeting from his cabin in
the middle of the night.
Oops, sorry, I got my commanders
mixed up for a moment.
To me, New Orleans is the American Dream
writ large in Dayglo colors,
and it takes the word dream literally
in that it advances in symbolic form
images meant to embody
not just possibilities,
hidden yearnings, hungers, and needs,
but also warnings of danger
perhaps too deep and threatening
to face straight on.
What could be more
dream-like, more symbolic,
and more troublingly
American than the uproar
around the removal of the stone effigies
of Jefferson Davis and Robert E. Lee
from the perches where they were set up
over a century ago to remind the citizenry
of a white supremacy that seemed
lost during Reconstruction,
but that had been reclaimed quickly
by the oh-so-brave men
riding masked in hoods
to reassert white dominance.
What could be more
dream-like than individuals
from inside and outside the
city watching the removals
dressed in Confederate flag bandanas
and Yes We Can t-shirts
with Barack Obama's likeness on them,
youths in Army fatigue
jackets with peace symbols,
and motorcycle guys with denim vests
carrying automatic weapons.
You saw all of it if you
were there, which I was.
You would think that the Civil
War had never been settled
and that the fate of the Union
still hangs in the balance,
and it does, it does.
We've entered a time now
in which the word American
has been hijacked by thieves
in suits and flag lapel pins
who assert that America
means white people,
not people of color, straight
nuclear family people,
not gay or transgender people,
certainly not immigrants,
while they rob the country blind
under the cloak of law and order
with a sociopathic
six-year-old at the helm,
madder by far than Captain Ahab,
attempting to push large
groups of Americans
and aspiring Americans to the margins,
often by executive orders
that would write them out
of the very definition of American;
black lives, women's lives,
lives of the appropriately-named Dreamers,
all of whom find it necessary to insist
as a means of their very survival
on their distinct identities.
Turning and turning in the widening gyre,
the falcon cannot hear the falconer,
things fall apart, the center cannot hold,
mere anarchy is loosed upon the world,
wrote Yeates, of course,
in The Second Coming,
and perhaps it is not mere anarchy,
but a carefully crafted shadow
play of mass distraction
allowing a small percentage
of vested brigands
to steal the silver and gold.
In the introduction to
Devil Sent the Rain,
my essay collection,
speaking of developments
during the George W. Bush administration
I wrote the following;
The divisions that were being
wedged more and more deeply
into the national dialogue
were psychological,
even mythological.
What were once differences
of policy and even philosophy
had become coated with
magic and superstition.
Manipulations cunningly crafted to bypass
the reasoning faculty
and go right to the heart
of the fear and uncertainty
that were there under the crust,
like rich oil reserves
that could be tapped
to fuel a brutal expansion.
The question became whether
there was an opposing magic
to counteract the enormous
undertow of all that imagery,
all that appealed to easy,
comforting answers, end quote.
And that was written about a
time 10 years ago and more,
amid a landscape of discourse
that was downright athenian
compared to the slop bucket we're in now.
Is there a cure?
Must things fall apart?
I asked myself that
question after Katrina,
revisiting the broken
city, my home that I loved,
and that many wanted to write off,
but that needed to be fought for.
Could New Orleans offer
not just a dream warning
for the nation, but a dream
hint of a way forward?
Eight.
I hit my stride as a fiction writer,
and maybe as an improviser,
on my first trip to New Orleans in 1987.
I had landed in town to spend a week
trying to recover from a broken heart,
and to attend the Jazz
and Heritage Festival
which I had wanted to do for years.
On arrival I found that my accommodations
were going to be different than I thought;
I was either going to have to share a bed
with the proprietor of the guest house
that I had booked sight unseen
from some sketchy advertisement.
I should say, this is before,
for those of you undergraduate age,
this was before the internet,
this was before Airbnb, HomeAway, Expedia,
whatever it might be, this was like,
you looked in advertisements
and it was like closing your eyes
and throwing a dart, really.
Which though proffered as an option,
what I mean, sharing the
bed with the proprietor
was not one as far as I was concerned,
or to sleep on a folding
cot in the kitchen
where I had spotted several cockroaches
that resembled good sized
cigar butts, only ambulatory.
(audience laughing)
I took a moment or three to wrap my brain
around the situation.
This was not the New Orleans
groove that I had imagined,
but as if one set of assumptions
were being slid off of me
like a decal and another
slid into place, I thought,
no man, you wanted to come to New Orleans,
this is what it is, this is
the hand you've been dealt,
deal with it or don't deal with it.
And I thought I'll deal with it,
so I slept in the kitchen,
and the next night
a bonafide guest room
opened up, as if by magic.
But for me, the project of writing,
I'm sorry, the process of writing a novel
is very much like this.
You have one set of ideas when you embark,
and a provisional sense of
the map of the book, maybe,
but as you get into it and
find out that certain things
are less possible than
you thought they were,
and characters reveal
aspects of themselves
that you didn't anticipate,
you have to go with that,
you have to improvise a
response to the unforeseen,
and out of a series of such responses
your book begins to find its identity.
I don't know that all
writers work this way,
in fact I'm sure they don't,
but I do think that most
literary writers probably do.
Was it just a total coincidence
that I found my first voice
as a fiction writer on my
first visit to New Orleans?
I don't know, maybe, but I
sat at the Napoleon House
and wrote the first draft of
my first good short story,
Brownsville, by the way, that
was the first one I wrote
where I really actually felt coordinated,
wrote the first draft of my
first short story Brownsville,
and in fact when I sent
it in to Gordon Lish,
great editor, legendary
editor Gordon Lish,
used to add fiction for
Esquire and other places,
when I sent it in to Gordon
Lish's magazine The Quarterly,
I sent it in under a
pseudonym, an assumed identity,
a mask, if you will.
I will not tell you what it is
because I might need it again someday,
leave it that I had literally found
another way to be myself,
if self is even really the right word.
But New Orleans would
teach me many more lessons
in years to come.
Some lessons were welcome,
and some were not,
but even the unwelcome
ones proved to be useful
as I improvised my responses,
and one of the lessons,
maybe the most important,
was that rarely is anything
exactly what it seems
on first glance.
So let me tell you a
little story about that
to close out this lecture.
Shortly after I arrived
in New Orleans to live,
which was in 1994, after years of visiting
every chance I could find,
I made the acquaintance of
a Mardi Gras Indian chief
named Donald Harrison.
Big Chief Donald Harrison,
somebody's nodding their head,
Big Chief of the Guardians
of the Flame Tribe.
Can I reasonably assume
that most of you know
what Mardi Gras Indians were,
by the way, I should ask,
raise your hand if you
don't know, I wanna see.
If you don't know, okay,
alright, don't be afraid,
okay good, everybody knows, terrific.
So Donald Harrison was the
chief of this particular gang,
he's also the father of the
wonderful jazz saxophonist
Donald Harrison, Jr.
Anyway, so you know,
the Mardi Gras Indians,
gangs of African Americans
who spend most of every year
sewing elaborate feathered
costumes that they wear
for the first time on Mardi Gras day,
and then only a couple
more times afterward,
and making a new one the
next year and so forth.
The tradition goes well
back into the 19th century,
as I said before, their visual
impact is often overwhelming,
as is the sound of their chanted songs
and rhythmic accompaniment.
I wish we had some film
footage to show right now,
but there's plenty in Treme for sure.
I no longer remember exactly
how I met Chief Donald,
although I had seen him dressed
in one of his astonishing
suits, assemblages,
like all Mardi Gras Indian
suits, consisting of feathers
and beaded pectorial
patches sewn onto canvas,
and jewels in geometric arrangements,
explosions of glorious
invention and grandeur.
Whatever the circumstances,
I must have expressed an interest
in talking to him about
the Indians, and he,
with a very characteristic New
Orleans generosity of spirit,
invited me to meet him for a
drink at a bar in the Treme,
by some accounts the oldest
continuously occupied
African American neighborhood
in North America,
in New Orleans, just across Rampart Street
from the French Quarter,
it's where it begins.
So I showed up and waited for
him for about half an hour
until through the bar's gloomy half light
I saw him approaching,
a very different figure
from the one I had last seen decked out
in powder blue plumes and feathers,
engaged in a verbal duel
with some other Indian chief.
This was a trim man in a very natty jacket
and stingy brim pork
pie hat, he greeted me
and we fell easily into conversation,
and this is how I described the encounter
in my book Why New Orleans Matters,
rather than try to strain
to recast it for y'all,
just to tell you how it goes.
I said we chatted for a
while but this and that,
he asked me what kind of work I did
and I told him that I write books.
He asked me what kind and
I told him both fiction
and nonfiction, and that I
wrote a lot about music as well.
I asked him if he liked to read,
and he told me he did.
When I asked him what he
liked to read he said,
"Mainly philosophy and some fiction.
"I have an extensive library
of books on philosophy
"and African American history as well."
This surprised me.
I thought I knew what and who
the Mardi Gras Indians were,
and I was surprised to hear this man,
whom I had seen dressed in
elaborate Indian regalia,
plumes and feathers sprouting,
chanting African-based rhythms
over tambourine background,
say that he read philosophy.
To my shame I had a moment of skepticism
that lay beneath my next question,
which was which philosophers
do you like to read?
"Lately," he said,
"mainly Bertrand Russell,
"but I love Nietzsche too."
It's an old American situation of course,
anyone interested in an
extended essay on the subject
should read Ralph Ellison's The
Little Man at Chehaw Station
in his collection Going to the Territory,
or Constance Rourke's
Seminole book-length study,
American Humor.
By the way, I wanna
recommend that book to you,
it's dated in some respects,
it came out in 1931.
Constance Rourke is one of
the most unjustly neglected
cultural historians who's
ever done that thing,
and her book American
Humor is indispensable.
In fact, I learned about
it from Ralph Ellison
and his friend Albert Murray,
also a Tuskegee-educated
novelist, a nonfiction writer.
Anyway, both of these
books extended meditations
on the masks not just
that we put on for others,
but that we put on others.
It's a lesson that one
has to learn continually
in New Orleans, it's the end of the quote,
and, I would add, in
our lives as Americans,
improvising our way
through a continuously-evolving landscape
of possibility and identity.
And I'm gonna leave it there,
and now I'll improvise
some responses to questions
or remarks if you have any.
I wanna thank you very
much for your attention.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
Any questions, any remarks,
any balls to serve me
over the net, I'll hit it back if I can.
Okay, yes?
- [Audience Member]
What is your connection
between jazz and the act of writing?
- Ah, the question if
you couldn't hear it was
what's my connection between jazz
and the act of writing you said?
Well, there are probably
a few different ways
I could answer that,
and they all probably go back
to the idea of improvisation,
although I don't consider jazz
to be strictly an improvisatory form,
I think improvisation
is inextricably bound up
with jazz music.
For me, I can answer maybe
in two or three parts.
For one thing, my notion of
the process of generating
a fictional narrative
is very improvisatory
to which I usually have some
kind of provisional sense
when I start out of what
the cord changes will be.
By the way, the person
who asked this question
is a dear old friend of mine
who I have not seen for probably 40 years,
Brian Torff, who's one of the
finest American bass players,
great jazz bass player, and other genres,
so that's where that question comes from.
So the cord changes in effect,
one might have a sense that one's gonna,
one thinks one's gonna start out playing
I'll Remember April and you find out
you were really playing Stardust,
but you have to get into
the text to find that out.
So the process of composition entails
constantly being alive to the things
that are being suggested
to you by the text
that you've already generated,
so it's improvisatory in that sense.
And then of course one has the luxury,
if one's a fiction writer,
of going back and re-writing,
which of course Sonny
Rollins doesn't have,
so there's that.
Second of all, and I guess
I'm gonna have to paraphrase
something I was saying in
response to one of the students
in the class this afternoon,
I experience the writing of prose
in a musical way, and even
in a choreographic way
in a sense, which is
that one is dealing with
the manipulation,
I don't like the overtone
series of that particular word,
but one's dealing yes,
with the manipulation
of the passage of time,
and the nature of sequence,
and the fact of sequence,
which is every bit as important
in writing fiction as it
is in five card stud poker
where you roll the cards one at a time.
You're trying to set up expectations
and then either subvert
them, or satisfy them
in some kind of surprising
and agreeable way,
and coherent way.
Well, the same thing could be said
about playing a jazz solo,
or playing in a jazz group,
but specifically with the sentences
and the progress of paragraphs,
one can spend an entire
Ulysses on One Day in Dublin,
or one can also go through
30 years in a paragraph,
so that is the manipulation of time.
There's a great performance
by John Coltrane,
any jazz fans in the house,
people like jazz here?
Couple, two people?
Don't be ashamed to raise your hands,
stick up for jazz music,
well there's a great
recording by John Coltrane
called Blue Train, it's
the title of an album
and of a track on there, it's a blues,
and in it Trane, Coltrane,
at certain places
would be playing many, many notes over,
it's a walking tempo blues,
about like this maybe,
right about there, and
sometimes he's playing melodies
that go (mimicking quick
jazz saxophone music),
sort of like that, maybe 32nd
notes or whatever they are,
and then he'll start playing
eighth notes and quarter notes,
and it's as if, it's again a
metaphor I used in class today,
but it's as if at a certain point
there's stuff going by
a train window so fast
that it's a blur, and
then suddenly you come out
into open country and you
see a farmhouse, whatever.
So I can't help that kind
of synesthetic dimension
of writing prose, narrative
prose specifically,
and I find it actually
a very tenable analog
to playing jazz.
Does that answer the question?
(laughs) Okay, man, sure.
Who else?
Do I have to ask myself questions?
Okay, go 'head, sure.
- [Audience Member] At
face value this was great,
and (voice trailing off).
But I wanna set you a problem,
and you can refuse it, but--
- Hmm, that's quite a lead in, okay.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Well,
it's about improvisation,
and Treme is such a romantic association
for a particular neighborhood,
but New Orleans is a conglomeration
of many neighborhoods,
and I wonder what would
happen if we set the cast
just throughout other neighborhoods,
and if different storylines,
because it's a multi-plotted series
of all kinds of different
places activated,
but what a different emphasis it would be
if the series were called Bywater,
or Midtown, or Faubourg Marigny.
(laughing)
But just improvise on
shifting the emphasis
on how the storylines would change
because of those neighborhoods,
valuing the fact that it's
not just one place, it's many.
- What an interesting question,
did everybody hear it, basically?
Okay what if, you heard it, alright,
so I won't try to recapitulate it,
basically what if the series were called,
named for some other
neighborhood in New Orleans,
even though Treme takes
in many, many different,
the series addressed itself
to many different places in New Orleans,
what if the accent were placed
on a different syllable,
and it were named for a
different neighborhood?
I think, in a way...
Well, what is a title in the first place?
A title serves some kind of
a God function, doesn't it?
In that a title is related to a text
the way God is related to
creation, in one way at least,
which is to say it addresses
itself, or sheds light upon,
looks over the entire
scope of the narrative
that it applies to.
So in that sense, a title functions
almost like a bit of a creation myth,
so you're saying here is the
root of meaning in this text.
So if you were to title
the series Bywater,
right away you're writing about something,
now it may take in every neighborhood,
but you're saying the
wellspring of meaning
is the experience of people
who, and institutions,
that are peculiar to this
area, to this neighborhood.
If you were to title it French
Quarter, that's been done,
or if you were to title
it any one of, Lower Nine,
pardon me, sorry, or if you
were to title it Gentilly,
each one of these titles would suggest
that somehow the experience or the fact
of this particular lineage of experience
is somehow going to cast a light
that encompasses everything else,
so you'd have a completely
different creation myth,
in a sense.
Now with Treme, and I
did not title the series,
and I've never been convinced
that it was necessarily absolutely
the ideal title for the
series, but whatever.
For one thing, because
people kept asking me
if I wrote for Treem.
(audience laughing)
Is that a title, is that a soda?
Anyway, so whether it was
the ideal title or not,
I think what it was saying,
being that it was this
historically ancient, really,
African American settlement, neighborhood,
within New Orleans, it is saying something
about African American
culture in New Orleans
as being foundational to the city,
and fructifying to all
the different narratives
in all parts of the city.
That may be an impossibly
romantic view of it,
but I don't think it's
completely off the wall.
And I think that's what would change,
I don't wanna go through
all the different possible
parameters, permutations
of, but that's, I think,
how it would change,
that's the nature of how it would change,
that's an improvised answer.
Ha, it was alright? Okay.
Thanks Jerry, yeah, Jeff?
- [Jeff] This is great, thank you for,
- Sure, no, no, go.
- [Jeff] When I think about,
so I love, sticking with improvisation,
and I guess maybe I just want
you to say a little more,
improvise a little
more, for improvisation,
I know you've been (garbled speaking),
and when I saw the title
as an occupational hazard,
the two phenomenon that I thought of
were sex and teaching.
- Were what?
- Sex and teaching.
- Two things that shouldn't
be combined a whole lot,
necessarily.
- Except I think of,
as you said, certain jazz is not entirely
an improvisatory format, though
that's true about (mumbles),
that contradiction in terms
is true of everything,
there's always some kind of form,
teaching is just sort
of endlessly exhausting
improvising sometimes, and of course sex,
but also there's a form that
outside of a certain range
is no longer teaching,
and it's no longer sex,
it's sexual assault, or
it's whatever else it is.
And so I guess, whatever,
I'm going on a tangent,
but the point is, I wonder, one,
what exactly you mean by improvising,
what is masking an example of in the talk,
and what do you think
of as a kind of form of
improvisation when it comes to that?
- Okay, it's a multipart question,
so what are some examples
of masking in the talk.
- [Jeff] What is masking just
an example of in the talk,
because I take it improvisational
as a kind of liquidity
to identity that you're
searching or locating
and finding identity, and
so is masking an example,
the good kind of masking an
example of improvising identity?
- Well, I think it always, masking I think
probably always entails
an injunction to improvise
because you're going to find yourself
in an unaccustomed situation.
I mean, unless it's the same
mask you wear every week,
but even then, even then.
Now, of course we find ourselves
in unscripted situations
even when we're not, quote,
unquote, wearing a mask,
but a lotta times a mask is put on you,
we're constantly measuring the temperature
of any situation, the slant
of light in any situation,
how does this person see me,
what are the assumptions this person has?
I walk into this room as a person
that I have my own understanding,
maybe, provisional,
of who I am, I walk into this room
and it's a bunch of people
who are going to have
certain class assumptions about me,
or certain ethnic assumptions.
So we're constantly
improvising our responses
to these situations.
One of the things that masks can do
is allow you to control
that a little bit more.
Like okay, I understand
what this Frankenstein mask
is gonna say to a number of people,
I see they're gonna see it as a quotation
about a monster movie, so they
can be relating to the mask
while I'm doing something else,
this is one of the great
advantages of masking.
For instance, you could
have a president, let's say,
who was a complete swindler, deadbeat,
really mentally deficient,
and really out to bilk everybody
from every last dollar
that they have if he could,
but who presents himself
as a great populist.
Hey, you know these
guys, blah, blah, blah,
so people who want to see that mask,
you can use that mask to
manipulate and steal the silver,
and we're living through
that now, in my opinion.
But a mask, in other words,
I think allows you to
control the circumstances of
the improvisation, in a way,
and maybe to a degree that
you wouldn't be able to
if you just came out as
yourself, because after all,
even our sense of our own
selves is very fragmented
most of the time.
We talk very glibly
about who we are, myself,
this is who I, this is my identity.
Your identity is about
12 or 14 different things
at any given time anyway,
you're one person,
this is a dull thing to
say, it's so obvious,
and said so often, but
we're different people
with our parents, with our
friends, lovers, whatever.
So the nature of improvisation
to me is just presence,
finally, and a quality of
alertness to the implications
of what is being dealt you at that time.
Now, were you saying you
wanted an example of masking
from the--
- No, no.
- Oh, alright, okay, but
does this make sense,
what I'm saying, does
that adequately address
what you were raising?
Will, did you have something
you were gonna ask?
- Yeah, I was just saying,
this reminds me a lot of an exhibit I saw
at the Jazz Museum, it was
part of the P4 Eve this year,
it was called The Lotus
In Spite of the Swamp,
but it was actually an exhibit
on the Mardi Gras Indians
and at the beginning
they had a short poem by,
it's Kalamu Ya Salaam from the Ninth Ward,
and just a quote that he had is that
New Orleans is both and
rather than either/or,
and so I felt like this
resonates with your talk.
And I was just wondering, do you think,
you might not be able
to answer this question,
but my question is what
do you think the source
of that identity is in New Orleans,
do we think it's just
an accident of history,
the fact that in many ways the
oldest people in New Orleans
are not the Americans, but the Creoles,
and then also in southern
Louisiana the Cajuns,
and the people from the
Caribbean, et cetera,
and now for to be the truest New Orleanian
is not necessarily be the trust American,
or is it something that
has developed uniquely
in the subsequent years?
- What a question, or,
yeah, it's a question.
There's so many things that are germane
to New Orleans history where you could say
well, here's the historical reason
why this kind of thing
developed in this way,
and I don't have enough of
the actual factual history
at my fingertips where I could say well,
here was the thing,
when the Germans settled
this neighborhood,
so I can't approach the
question from that angle.
What I can say is that first and foremost,
first and foremost, above everything else,
New Orleans is a port.
So any time you have a port you have
an extraordinarily
heterogeneous population
that is engaged in a lot of
different kinds of activity,
some of which is very opportunistic,
some of which is exploratory,
people are leaving,
people are coming in who are strangers,
you've got all the ingredients
of every kind of story right there.
The departure on an adventure,
on a voyage of discovery,
the arrival in town of the stranger,
you've got it all mixed together,
so all of these narratives,
these different types of narratives,
are mixing together in an active port
to a degree that they don't, let's say,
in the mythic small town, in
which there's a certain stasis
and then it's disturbed a
little bit by this or that
irregularity of whatever sort.
So New Orleans, first of all,
even without anything
else going on, is a port,
and it has all that implied
injunction to improvisation
based on all these (mic falling),
can I please get rid of this thing?
- It's for the video.
- What is this?
- [Man] I think it's
the mic for the video.
- Yeah, I think maybe we--
- It has to be there, okay.
Hey, how you doing, alright.
So what was I talking about?
Oh yeah...
So it's an improvisatory
situation to begin with,
but especially because of the,
first of all it had this
peculiar double quality
of being one of the most
active slave markets
that there was, especially
for a certain period,
and at the same time
having a huge population
of free people of color, so right away
you're in a kind of hall
of mirrors right away.
Then you had neighborhoods
that were settled successively
by the French, by the
Spanish, we know this,
other neighborhoods that
were pockets of Italian,
New York City shares some of that quality,
so you have all that
mixture of cultural richness
and also mutual suspicion,
and cultural blending,
all of that stuff that comes from having
a very diverse population
in any situation,
so all of that is there.
Also, and I could go on and on about this,
but one of the other
things about New Orleans
was that specifically
African, and Afro-Caribbean,
but specifically African
cultural elements were,
maybe by an accident of
civic law or something,
allowed to be expressed publicly
in a way that they weren't
in a lot of places.
Many of you have probably
heard of Congo Square,
which was this area in New Orleans
right on one side between
Basin and Rampart Street,
where enslaved people
could go and play drums,
African drumming, outside, and dance,
this was back even in the 18th
century, the 19th century,
so what the ethnographers
sometimes call African retentions
were just out there in plain sight,
and were an animating,
supremely animating,
dimension of the city's cultural life,
from way back and way back.
So I guess I'm losing the
thread of the question
maybe a little bit, but I
take it that you're asking me
why is New Orleans such a
diverse place or something,
why is there such an injunction
to improvisation there?
But I think any time that
you have all that cultural,
historical, ethnic, whatever
you wanna say, contrast
you're gonna have that, and
then specifically add to that
the port city dimension,
and the fact that it was a
French colony for a long time,
that too gave this somewhat
different casts, many reasons.
I suggest if you wanna
read an excellent book
about New Orleans history,
especially the early part
of New Orleans history,
Tulane professor Lawrence
Powell wrote a book
called The Accidental
City, and that's, I think,
probably the best history
of early New Orleans
that you could read, and
if you haven't read it,
especially you being from New Orleans,
you might wanna check that out.
Yes.
- [Joe] I think that'll
be the last question.
- To the man in the blue watch cap.
- [Audience Member] Well
I was just wondering about
if you could say more about,
so you talked about New Orleans
is the American Dream writ large,
but then you talked about also
there are protective warnings of dangers
too threatening to consider.
And I'm wondering, I don't know,
just that I was struck
by that, by that idea,
and I wondered if you
had more to say about it,
about climate disaster, for example,
or about the ways in which
the fabric of the union
feels like it's being rent asunder.
Yeah, tell me what was
going on in your mind
when you were writing that,
what do you have to define that?
- Okay, I'll try to do
that in as compact a time,
are we worried about time?
- No.
- Okay fine, good.
When I said it was the
American Dream writ large,
what I mean by that is
that a broad spectrum of
cultural affiliation is
allowed an extraordinary
wide pallet upon which
to, each one is able to,
you have French, Spanish,
you have all of these
ethnic, regional, national identifiers
really being out there in
full view, in full expression,
vigorous full expression,
and yet also at the same time
contributing to these syncretic forms
that are combinations of
these different identifiable
ethnic and whatever else, traditions.
So to me, that is the
American Dream, for me,
because I think that the dream,
which is not necessarily the reality,
God knows, all the time,
is that we maintain
a fruitful tension between
where we came from,
however you might wanna read that,
and what might be possible for us.
Whether it's gender transformation,
whether it's singing music
from a completely different
tradition than ours,
as Saul Bellow said,
whatever you're strong enough
to carry out, it's yours,
as long as you do something
interesting with it.
So by American Dream I suppose
that's what I meant by that.
Now, as far as warnings and dangers, well,
you said it yourself,
we also see the American tendency,
well don't call it an American tendency,
it's a human tendency, to
figure that we don't need
to really be super
proactive in our stewardship
of elements of the geography,
physical or otherwise,
that are meant to preserve our wellbeing.
So whether that's, oh, the
levies, yeah right, well,
I gotta go home and
watch the football game,
I won't do the inspection
today, or whatever it might be,
whatever levels of incompetence
or just bad attention obtained,
we see that in New Orleans,
New Orleans has suffered from
that, from climate change
all the way down to just about everything
that you could think about about the city.
And initially, I started to feel
that the lecture was
getting a little bit long,
so I cut out a long section that I had
quoting from Devil Sent the
Rain in a piece that I wrote
after the BP oil spill, do y'all remember
the Deep Water Horizon?
This was 2010, and the pipeline burst,
and there were millions, or
billions, who's counting,
gallons of oil being shot out
into some of the most
ecologically sensitive waters
on the planet, and everybody kept saying,
oh you poor guys down there,
first Katrina, now this.
And I thought, what that was about
was people not caring enough to make sure
that there were safety precautions.
Oh my God, regulation, God forbid,
and I thought, that's
not you guys down there,
have you ever heard of ENRON?
Have you ever heard of WorldCom?
Sorry, everybody's probably
forgotten about that by now,
savings and loan scandal?
Okay, you gotta be of a certain age.
How about the fact that
the entire world economy
just about imploded in 2008
as a result of the loosening
of the intolerable chains
around the limbs of
the beleaguered banking
and securities industries?
I'm sorry, industry.
Those regulations were so 1933,
and we got what we were asking for.
And it's a human problem, but we have seen
the specific action, I'm
sorry, specific accent,
in which that problem
has been articulated,
and it's a very American accent,
and I would say that
New Orleans has shown us
some of the most vivid waking dreams
that could represent that
danger that we've had.
WorldCom, ENRON, all that stuff
didn't offer these searing dreams
to trouble the sleep of the republic,
and New Orleans has, but
they're representative.
Yeah, that work for you?
- Yeah, that works for me.
- Okay.
Everybody, I wanna thank
you so much, thank you.
(audience applauding)
(light, twinkling music)